one of my favorite lines in this episode  and i do love that we did this is uh is  when danny pulls the gun out and says  falcon yes so clearly frank had seen the  made for or the edited for tv version of  die hard because the actual line in the  movie is yippie kaye [ __ ] and  you can't say that on tv so the tv edit  was yippie kaye mr falcon yeah mr factor  and it was like a different voice like  it wasn't bruce willis so it was like  yep  mr belkin it was like the  you know the engineer like was like oh  [ __ ] we missed one he never said oh i i  got it let me i can do it i'll do it mr  falcon  too close to the mic and yeah yippee  kaye mr falcon i just wonder how that's  there's got to be a better substitute  for [ __ ] than mr falcon there  isn't  that's the greatest  [Music]